And I think there are two correct answers here.
The first one is indeed that randomized algorithms are in some way
more difficult to trick into a worst-case behavior than deterministic algorithms.
Now, to illustrate this for example think about the greedy algorithm
that we use to approximate vertex cover.
We could trick that approximation algorithm into a worst-case behavior
simply because we expose the way that it works
and we knew how it would work because it works deterministically.
For randomized algorithm, of course, we never quite know what it is going to do.
So, constructing a worst-case instance or finding an instance
that really exposes worst-case behavior here
might in some way be more difficult than for deterministic algorithm.
Randomized algorithms can definitely be easier to analyze than deterministic algorithms
although of course this one is a little bit debatable
since statistics and probability can also get very nasty
but when you get down to search tree analysis versus the analysis of random algorithms
and with what probability they produce correct results
usually these over here are easier, and we also had that in the last quiz where I mentioned it.
Now, finally a random algorithm does not explore solutions that a deterministic algorithm would miss.
Rather, it's the other way around.
The deterministic algorithm at least if it's not in the approximation algorithm
will always guarantee that you find a correct solution.
On the other hand, with the randomized algorithm, you know about your probabilities
because you're demanding guarantees, but nevertheless, you can never be 100% sure.
You might be 99.9999% sure that it produces the correct answer but never 100.